for me the most fascinating aspect of
the Pluto files was watching the depth
of emotion that people brought to bear
on what they would believe to be the
scientific reason for why they hold
those thoughts for why they have those
beliefs so in other words you would say
I think Pluto is a planet
well why and then they give a list of
scientific reasons but they'd be like
weak reasons they'd be because I watched
it happen
I watched it so people say please apply
awhile because it has a moon and planets
have moons and then a few years later we
found that an asteroid had a moon so
they couldn't use that argument anymore
because it was an unimpeachable heed
little potato shaped asteroid and so
they had those sort of abandon that they
say well Pluto and just to watch
arguments come and go and you realize
that at the end of the day it's all
about people's emotions not all but
predominantly and I was intrigued by
this because it's emotions that drives
art rational thoughts never drives
people's creativity the way emotions do
and so the the the the controversy
jumped species and it went out of the
scientific community out of the
classroom and landed in the laps of
humorists of cartoonists of of op-eds
op-eds and everybody took a piece of
pluto death by black hole is a
collection of my essays that I'd written
over 10 years for Natural History
Magazine and there's the title essay
called death by black hole in a section
titled when the universe turns bad all
the ways the cosmos wants to kill us you
talked about gamma-ray bursts and
asteroid strikes and that sort of thing
but by and large in spite of that title
the book is predominantly about how
science works with sections titled the
nature of the discoverer of discovery
and the discovery of nature the how
we've come to learn what we
know about the universe and so I've
gotten very good feedback very positive
feedback on that book because people
it's not just telling you what to know
it's empowering you how to think about
the physical world and about that I'm
proud that I've succeeded in that way it
was a bad side benefit that I had not
anticipated I thought that as a minimum
I teach a little bit about black holes
and and the universe but people have
been have deeply appreciated and
resonated with the rest of what the book
is which allows you to take on a little
bit of the lens that so many scientists
take for granted it's the lens of
curiosity folded with the lens of the
empowerment of a thought this is not
simply what to know about the universe
it's how to think about the universe so
you can go on and feel more connected
than you ever had been before
I want to write a book on on the
educational system how best to train
people to think to be scientifically
literate I think is important something
we're lacking in school we think
scientific literacy science literacy
flows out of well how many science facts
can you recite rather than how is your
brain wired for thinking and it's the
brain wiring that I'm more interested in
rather than the the facts that come out
of the curriculum or the lesson plan
that's been proposed